Well, last time we turn to questions
about the morality of suicide,
and I started with two arguments that
are called quicken dirty arguments.
I suppose it would have been fair to
say that they were really theological
arguments,
so or they were moral arguments that
used in pars theological premises.
I suggested that at least,
okay,
if we look at them at the end there,
quick and dirty versions,
they were inadequate,
and if we'll go ahead and make a more
careful argument about the morality of
suicide,
we need to turn to a more systematic
view about the contents of,
of morality.
We need to look at suicide in terms
of the basic moral principles. Now,
that's not something we've got
the chance to do in detail,
but I think we can at least say enough
about a couple of basic approaches to the
contents of morality or the basic
moral rules to get the beginnings of an
understanding of what might emerge
about the morality of suicide.
If we were to do that more carefully.
So hold off on suicide for the moment.
Let's ask ourselves,
what is it that makes an action morally
acceptable or morally forbidden?
This is unsurprisingly something that
different moral theories disagree about,
but there's at least one factor or one
feature that all or almost all moral
theories agree about and that is that
the consequences of your action matter.
That is we might or might not think that
consequences are the only thing that
are morally relevant. When we think
about the morality of your action,
but surely it is one thing
that's morally relevant.
What are the consequences
of your action going to be?
So let's think about the morality of
suicide with an eye towards consequences.
Bearing in mind that it, since we're
talking about a moral point of view,
we need to take into account
the consequences as they
affect everybody. Now,
the person who of course is most affected
by suicide is of course the person
who's killing themselves.
And at first glance it might seem pretty
clear that the consequences of suicide
are bad for that person.
After all the person was alive and now
they're dead and we normally would take
death to be a bad result. You know,
if I were to tell you, you know,
here's a switch on the wall.
If you were to flip the switch,
a thousand people who would
otherwise be alive would end up dead.
You would normally take that
to be a pretty compelling
argument against flipping
the switch. Why? Because the
results would be bad. Why?
Because a thousand people
would end up dead. Well,
one person ending up dead isn't as bad
as a thousand people ended up dead.
But for all that,
shouldn't we still say it's a bad
consequence and it's a result of that?
Shouldn't we say that?
However far appeal to consequences goes
in terms of giving us our moral theory?
Yeah.
Don't we have to say in terms of
consequences are with regard to suicide is
immoral but not so quick.
Even though it's true that
normally death is a bad thing,
it's not always a bad thing.
This is the sort of thing that we've
learned by thinking about what does the
badness of death consistent,
typical cases are ones in
which the person's dying
robs them of a chunk of life
that would have been good for them.
Overall and because of that
dying then is bad for them.
But in the kinds of cases
that we're thinking about
cases where suicide would be
rationally acceptable and we're now
asking whether or not it's morally
acceptable in those sorts of cases,
at least the kind of paradigm
examples that we've been focused on,
the person is better off dead,
they're better off dead,
meaning that what life
now holds out for them,
although perhaps not negative through
and through, is negative on balance.
It's negative on balance.
They're not better off continuing
to live the better off dying,
and that means of course the dying isn't
bad for them, but rather good for them.
And so their death is
not a bad consequence,
but rather a good consequence provided
that you're prepared to accept the
possibility of cases in which somebody
will be better off if their life ended
sooner rather than later.
We're led to the conclusion that from the
moral point of view as far as focusing
on consequences goes to consequences
might actually be good rather than bad.
If the person were to kill themselves,
they will free themself.
Let's suppose of the suffering they
would otherwise have to undergo.
Well, that's first glance said
consequences says suicide's wrong.
Second glance says consequences.
It says at least in certain circumstances,
suicides, right? Of course,
third glance suggests we can't just focus
on consequences for the person who's
contemplating suicide because from
the point of view of morality,
we have to look at the
consequences for everybody.
Who else might get affected by the
death or suicide of the of the person?
Well,
the most obvious people for us to think
about it that point then are the family
and loved ones.
The people who most directly know
about and care about the person who is
contemplating suicide, and again,
I'm running out of glances,
but at first glance you
might say, well, they're,
the consequences are clearly bad when
when the person kills themselves,
that causes typically a great deal of
distress for the family and friends of the
person who's killed themself.
Even if that's true,
we now have to ask how do the
consequences way out after all we,
we live in a world in which no single
app typically has only good consequences
or no single acts has bad consequences
and only bad consequences.
Often our choices are mixed packages
where we have to ask whether the good that
we can do is greater than the bad that
we'd be doing with this act or that act
or some third act.
Even if there are then
negative consequences in
terms of distressed and the
family, friends and loved ones
of the person who kills himself,
that might still be outweighed by the
benefit to the person himself or herself.
If it was really the case
that she'd be better,
he or she will be better off dying,
but it's also worth bearing in mind
that in so far as we're thinking about
people who will love and care about
the person who's considering dying,
then they may actually overall on balance
be relieved that this suffering of
their loved one has come to an end.
Look,
we will of course all be
horribly distressed that
that nature or the fates or
what have you,
has brought it about that this person's
choices are now reduced to killing
themselves on the one hand or continuing
this terminal stages of some illness
where they're incapacitated and in pain.
We will of course,
wish there was a serious
prospect of a cure,
some chance of recovery. Wish they'd
never gotten ill in the first place,
but given the limited choices,
continued suffering and
pain on the one hand,
or having an end to
that suffering and pain,
if the person can rationally assess
their prospects and reasonably come to
believe they're better off
dead than that's a judgment
their loved ones can come
to share as well.
They may well regret the
fact more than regret.
Curse the fact that these are
the all new choices they've got,
but still given the limited choices,
they may agree,
they may come to agree better
to put an end to the suffering.
And so when the person kills themselves,
they May 2nd that choice.
They may say at least they're
not in pain and agony anymore.
So if we look at it from the point
of view of consequences, in fact,
suppose we had a moral view that said
consequences are on just one thing that
was morally relevant.
In thinking about the right,
what makes it an action right or wrong?
Suppose we took the bold claim that
consequences are the only thing that's
morally relevant. There are moral
views that that that take his position.
I suppose the best known example of this
kind of consequence only approached him
morality is
utilitarianism is the moral
doctrine that says right and wrong.
As a matter of producing as much
happiness for everybody as possible,
counting everybody's happiness equally
and when you can't produce happiness than
at least trying to minimize
the misery and suffering,
counting everybody's misery
and suffering equally.
So suppose we accept this
utilitarian position.
What conclusions would we come to
then about the morality of suicide?
I suppose the conclusion would be a kind
of moderate one and the one hand we'd
be rejecting the extreme that says suicide
is never morally acceptable because
to say that you'd have to be claiming
suicide always has bad consequences
overall, and that strikes me,
although it's an empirical claim,
it strikes me as a rather
implausible empirical claim.
It's sadly enough,
not too difficult to describe cases in
which the results may actually be better
if the person kills themselves rather
than having their suffering continue.
It may be better for them
and better for their family.
On the other hand, we certainly
wouldn't want if we were utilitarians,
we also wouldn't want to go to the
other extreme and say suicide is always
morally acceptable because of course to
say that it's always morally acceptable
is to say that the consequences are
never bad when you kill yourself,
and that's also pretty obviously
an implausible thing to claim.
You guys are young, you're healthy,
you've got a great future in front of you.
If you were to kill yourself,
the results wouldn't be good.
The results would be worse overall
than if you had refrained from killing
yourself.
So utilitarian position is in the middle.
It doesn't say suicides,
never acceptable.
It doesn't say suicide
is always acceptable.
It says perhaps unsurprisingly
it's sometimes acceptable.
It depends on the facts.
It depends on the results.
It depends on comparing
the results of this action,
killing yourself to the
alternatives open to you.
We have to ask,
is your life worse than nothing?
Is there some medical procedure
available to you that would cure you?
If there is, and even if your
life is worse than nothing,
that still doesn't make it the best
choice in terms of the consequences.
Getting medical help is a preferable
We can even think of cases where
your life is worse than nothing.
You'd be better off dead and there is no
medical alternative of a cure available
to you.
But for all of that,
it still isn't morally legitimate to
kill yourself in terms of the utilitarian
outlook because as always we have to
think about the consequences for others.
And there may be others who'd be so
adversely affected by your death that the
harm to them outweighs the costs
to you of keeping yourself alive.
Suppose for example, that you're
the single parent of young children.
You've got a kind of moral obligation
to look after them if you were to die,
you know,
they really have it horribly.
It's conceivable that in cases like that,
the suffering of your children wore
you to kill yourself without way the
suffering that you'd have to undergo war
you to keep yourself alive for the sake
of your children.
So it all depends on the facts.
Still,
if we accept the utilitarian position,
we do end up with a moderate conclusion.
In certain circumstances,
suicide will be morally justified.
Roughly speaking in those cases where
you're better off dead and the effects on
others aren't so great
as to outweigh that,
those will be that sort of paradigm
cases in which suicide makes sense or as
legitimate morally speaking from
the utilitarian perspective.
Okay?
But of course,
that doesn't mean that suicide is indeed
ever morally legitimate because we
don't necessarily want to embrace
the utilitarian theory of morality.
Utilitarianism is what you get.
Roughly speaking.
When we say consequences matter
and there are all that matters,
but
most of us are inclined to think
that there's more to morality than
consequences.
Most of us are inclined to think that
there are cases in which actions can have
bad results,
whether actions can have good results
and yet for all that be morally forbidden
or actions could have bad results
and yet for all that still be morally
required. That's not to say that
consequences don't matter morally,
it's to claim rather that consequences
aren't the only thing that matter.
Morally. Consequences can be outweighed
by other morally relevant factors.
Well,
that's the position that's held by
the branch of moral theory known as
Deontology.
So deontologists say other things
matter morally besides consequences and
deciding whether or not your
action is right or wrong.
You have to pay attention
to the consequences,
but you have to pay attention
to the other things as well.
What other things?
Well and surprisingly,
this is a area in which
different deontologists we'll
disagree one to the next
in terms of what else they want to add
to the list of morally relevant factors.
But there's one kind of additional factor
that most of Austin are deontological
moods would want to add to the
list and that to this. So one,
at any rate that relevant,
I think most directly relevant
for thinking about suicide,
that factor is the factor of not just
what was the upshot of your action,
but how you produced that upshot,
not just what the results were,
but what was your means of getting those
results and more particularly still did
you have to harm anybody
to produce the results?
Most of us are inclined to think it's
wrong to harm people or at least innocent
people.
It's wrong to harm innocent people.
Even if the results of
doing that might be good.
Now I threw in the qualification about
innocent people because of course it's
also true that most of us are
inclined to think that sue,
a self defense might be justified,
uh,
harming people who are attacking you or
your friends or your fellow countrymen
that may be legitimate.
And so it's not as though we want to say
it's never legitimate to harm somebody,
but those people are guilty.
There are aggressors.
What most of us in our deontological
moods are inclined to think is it's never
legitimate to harm an innocent person.
And the crucial point is that's true.
Even if the results would be better.
Look,
there's no debate between deontologists
and utilitarians about harming innocent
people in the normal case.
Because normally of course, yeah,
I suppose that to make an example, to end
the class with a nice big bang, right,
I brought my Uzi submachine gun,
I now take it and go ratatat
tat killing 15 of you. Well,
that would not be something
that would have good results.
And so clearly the utilitarians
going to reject that as well as the
deontologists through an agreement
about that. And the typical case,
killing an innocent person
has bad results, harms
them. It's wrong. Full Stop.
We're done.
But what should we say about cases where
killing an innocent person has better
results?
Okay.
In real life,
it's hard to think of cases like that,
but we can at least go science
fictiony and tell an example.
So here's one of my favorite
examples. Uh, in moral philosophy,
suppose that we have five patients in a
hospital who are going to die because of
Oregon failures of one sort or another.
One of them needs a heart transplant.
One of them needs a kidney transplant,
one of them needs a liver
transplant and so forth and so on.
Unfortunately,
because of tissue incompatibilities,
even as they begin to die,
we can't use the organs from the ones
that have died to save the others.
Meanwhile,
here in the hospital for a routine
checkup is John John's perfectly healthy.
And as you're doing your exams on him,
you discover that he's exactly suitable
to be an organ donor for all five of the
patients.
And it occurs to you that if you were to
find some way to kill him but cover up
the cause of death so
it look like he died.
If some unexpected freak seizure,
you can then use his
organs to save the five.
This one gets the kidney, that one gets
the other kidney, that one gets the heart,
that one gets deliver,
that one gets the lungs.
So your choice roughly is this,
just give John his routine medical exam,
in which case the five other patients die
or chop up John Killam and chop him up
using his organs to
save the five patients.
Well, what should we say is the right
thing to do in the organ transplant case?
In terms of consequences, it looks
as though if we tell the story right,
at least their results would be
better if we chop up John after all,
it's one versus five and although the
death of John's a horrible bad result,
the death of the five is a horrible
bad result and saw the results would be
better if we were to kill innocent John.
Well, if we had more time we could argue
about are the results really going to be
better? Is that a realistic
story? What have you,
either other long term effects on the
health care profession that we haven't
taken into account,
but we don't have time to really
pursue this story in detail.
Let's just suppose we could
eventually get the details right.
The results really would be
better if we chopped up John,
is that the right thing to do?
Well,
maybe utilitarianism says
it's the right thing to do,
but it's precisely for that reason that
most of us would then say, you know,
there's more to morality than
what utilitarianism says.
Now whether that objections are good ones,
a very,
very complicated question and if you,
if you'd like to pursue it,
if you want to pursue it,
then I invite you to take an
introductory class in moral philosophy.
For our purposes,
let's just suppose that most of us are
on board with the deontologists when they
say there's more to morality than what
the utilitarian has and this example
brings it out.
It's wrong to kill
somebody who's innocent.
Even though by hypothesis the results
would be better. It's five to one.
People have a right to life,
a right not to,
he killed and that right ways in when
we're deciding what to do morally so that
it's wrong to kill an innocent person,
even if the results really
would be better. All right,
let's suppose we agree with
that. Agree. Except that again,
in a fuller class on more a philosophy
we'd have to ask ourselves what's the
basis of that, right? What
other deontological rights too?
People have what exactly are
the contours of that? Right?
But here we can just ask.
Suppose we accept a right like that.
What are the implications of that for
the morality of suicide and now it seems
what we have to say is suicide is wrong.
Suicide is morally unacceptable.
Because when I kill myself,
well I'm killing somebody.
And didn't we just say as deontologists
that killing an innocent person and I'm
an innocent person, killing an
innocent person is morally wrong. Well,
I'm a person,
so killing me is morally wrong.
And it's not really any help
to come back and say, but look,
we stipulated that this is a case
where the person's better off dead.
The results will really be better
overall if he kills himself. Said,
yeah, that's right. Maybe that
is right. It doesn't matter.
Because as deontologists we said
the right to life is so powerful,
it outweighs consequences.
Just as it was wrong to chop up John,
even though the results would be better,
five versus one drawn to kill yourself,
even if the results would be better,
even if that's the only way to put
yourself out of pain and those are good
results,
it doesn't matter.
The right to life outweighs
the appeal to consequences.
So as deontologists it seems we
have to say suicide is forbidden.
Stop.
Well as usual and philosophy,
it's not quite as simple as that one
possible response. Somebody might make us,
but look morality's only
about how I treat others.
It's not about how I treat myself
and if we were to accept that claim,
then we could say the right to life only
covers how I treat others in particular
rules up my killing. Other people,
even when the results would be good,
but it doesn't have any implications
for how I treat myself and in particular
then if the right to life
doesn't exclude self killing,
well then suicide is acceptable.
That's a possible moral view.
But I find it rather implausible if we
want to start to explain what it is about
you that explains why it's
wrong for me to kill you,
we'd start saying things about how well
you're a person and as such you've got
all these plans and so forth and so on.
And as a person you've got certain rights,
certain things that
shouldn't be done to you.
Yeah,
you're not just,
this is the thought that lies behind
much deontological thinking, right?
People aren't objects. We
can't just destroy them for
the sake of better results.
Well, that's right. People aren't objects,
but of course I'm a person too and
so when I contemplate killing myself,
I'm contemplating destroying a person.
So it's at least difficult to see why
we would accept the claim that morality
only governs how I treat other people,
it seems.
Although the issue is a complicated one,
which we don't have time
to pursue further today.
It seems to me more plausible to say
morality includes rules not only governing
how I treat others,
but also how I treat myself.
Yeah, if that's right and if among
the moral rules are a right to life,
a prohibition against harming people,
then don't we have to say, look, it's,
it's a, it's wrong from the deontological
perspective to to kill yourself.
Well, of course the natural response to
this line of thought is to say, but look,
when I kill myself, unlike the case of
chopping up John to say five others,
when I kill myself,
I'm doing it for my own sake.
I'm harming myself for my own sake.
That seems highly relevant in
thinking about the morality of suicide
does seem relevant though.
It's not a hundred percent clear
what to do with that thought.
Here's two possible interpretations
of that thought. First of all,
you might think that the,
the,
the relevance of saying that I'm
harming myself for my own sake is this.
If I'm harming myself for my own sake,
what I'm saying is,
despite the fact that I'm harming
myself, I'm better off. After all,
we stipulated that we were focusing on
cases in which suicide was rational,
so the person's better off dead if they're
better off dead, that'll cost then.
Although it's certainly true that there's
a sense in which they're harming you,
saw them killing yourself
as doing harm to yourself.
Still it's not harm overall.
The bottom line we were imagining
is positive when you kill yourself.
And so,
although unlike the case of John where
you've harmed him and benefited others,
so you have harmed him overall,
in the case of suicide,
when I harm myself to avoid the
suffering I would otherwise go through,
I'm not really as we might say,
harming myself overall.
So perhaps the deontological prohibition
against harm is really a prohibition
against harming people overall.
Look,
you, you got some sort of a
disease, uh, in your infection,
in your leg that has now spread and it's
going to kill you unless we amputate
your leg. So you go into surgery
and the surgeon shops off your leg.
Has He done something immoral?
It doesn't seem as though he has,
but after all, he chopped off your
leg. He harmed, you used to have a leg.
Now you don't have one.
Well,
what we want to say is he
didn't harm you overall.
He harmed you in such a way that it was
the only way to leave you better off
bottom line. And that's not a
violation of the rule against harming.
At least that's a possible thing to say.
And if that's the right thing to say that
maybe that's what we should say about
the suicide case yet again.
Yeah,
there's a deontological prohibition
against harming innocent people,
but what it's really a prohibition
against is leaving them worse off overall.
And when I kill myself,
I'm not leaving myself worse off overall.
And if that's right, and even from
the deontological perspective,
suicide may be morally legitimate.
Well,
that's at least one possible way to
carry out the deontological stand.
One passive way of interpreting the
remark, but look, when I kill myself,
I'm doing it for my own benefit.
Here's another possible way
of interpreting that thought
when I kill myself. Given that
I'm doing it for my own benefit,
I've obviously got my own agreement.
I can't kill myself against my will.
Suicide is something you do to yourself
and so I have my own consent to what I'm
doing.
That seems pretty important.
Notice how different it is from the
case of John. When I chopped up John,
I imagine I don't have John's approval.
Consent seems to be present
in the case of suicide,
but not in the case of chopping up John.
Maybe that's morally relevant as well.
Now to accept that view is of course to
say we need to add yet another factor
into our deontological theory. We
have consequences, we have harm doing,
but we also have the factor of consent
and so we need to think about the moral
relevance of having the consent of the
victim and once we thinking about that,
I think most of us would be inclined to
the accept the conclusion that consent
can make it acceptable to do to someone
what would normally be wrong in the
absence of their consent. By
the, by, you'll notice that,
that that seems to be one of
the things that's relevant.
And thinking about the surgery case,
not the organ transplant case, but uh,
performing the amputation
of the leg to save the, uh,
save the person who would otherwise die.
Yeah.
Surely it seems relevant that the
person that the patient has given you
permission to operate on them.
Here's another example that shows
you the relevance of consent.
It would not be okay.
It would not be morally acceptable for
me to go up and hit you in the nose
just like it wouldn't be okay for you
to go up and hit me in the face or the
gut.
And yet boxing matches are,
I suppose,
morally acceptable.
Why is that?
Because from a deontological perspective,
the answer is when people are boxing,
they've agreed to it.
I give you permission to hit me or at
least to try to hit me in exchange for
your giving me permission to hit
you or at least to try to hit you.
And it's the presence of that consent
that makes it permissible for you to harm
me. Assuming that you're
a better boxer than I am,
which I'm confident would
have to be the case.
So consent makes it legitimate to harm
people even though in the absence of
consent it wouldn't be legitimate.
Alright, if that's right,
then bring that thought home to
thinking about the case of suicide.
Suicide might be wrong because after all,
I'm a person at first glance,
but since I'm killing myself,
I've given myself permission.
I've given myself consent to harm myself,
and if consent makes it permissible to
do what would normally be forbidden,
Ben Consent makes it permissible
for me to kill myself.
And so now we're led again
to the conclusion that
from a more fully developed
deontological perspective,
we ought to say suicide is permissible.
At least if we're prepared to throw in
this kind of factor of consent and think
that it can just wipe out the protections
that would otherwise normally be in
place.
Indeed,
if we think that we're going to be led
to a rather bold and extreme conclusion
about the morality of suicide,
the persons killed himself.
So he's clearly consented.
And so in every case,
what he's done is acceptable.
Now maybe that's right,
if we're prepared to go that far
with the principle of consent,
but maybe we shouldn't go that
far with the principle of consent.
Suppose no, we're talking
after class and you say to me,
Shelly,
you've got my permission to kill me
and so I get out my gun
and I shoot you to death
doesn't seem morally acceptable.
Even though you gave me your permission.
Especially, you know, think
of even weirder cases.
Suppose that you are feeling like you
want to be killed because you're overcome
with guilt because you
believe you killed John Smith,
but you're crazy. You didn't
kill John Smith. John Smith,
not even dead, but in your
insanity, you think you did do it.
And so you say,
Shelley,
please kill me and I know that
you're insane, but hey, you know,
consent is consent and so I kill you.
Oh,
that clearly isn't acceptable.
Or suppose you know you're playing
with your three year old nephew.
He said, Oh yeah, I don't
really like being like kill me.
I clearly doesn't make it acceptable
to kill him or her nephew it to him.
So if we start accepting
this consent principle,
we're led to some pretty
implausible conclusions.
So maybe we should throw it out.
Maybe we should say no consent really
doesn't have the kind of power that a
minute ago it looked like it did.
But I'm inclined to think we shouldn't
go that far and throw away the consent
principle altogether because if we
do throw out the consent principle,
we're going to find ourselves on able
to say some things that I think it's
pretty important to us to say.
Consider the following an example.
Suppose that we're in war and uh,
we're in the foxhole and a a hand
grenades been thrown into the foxhole and
unless something happens quick,
the Hagmann it's going to blow up and it
will kill my five buddies who are near
the hand grenade, unfortunately because
they're playing cards, whatever,
they don't see it, but I see it.
But I don't have time to warn them.
By the time I tell them what's going on,
they won't have time to react.
Really. It's do nothing. Let
them get killed, but I will.
I'll probably won't be hurt very much
or throw myself on the hand grenade.
My body absorbs the blow,
saves my buddies, kills me.
Imagine what happens then is I
throw myself on the hand grenade.
I've sacrificed myself,
them,
I've done something amazing.
Few of us would have it
within ourselves to do this,
but amazingly enough,
some people do and we admire
and praise these people.
They've committed,
they've undertaken an incredible
act of heroic self sacrifice,
morally commendable above
and beyond the call of duty.
We want to say praise worthy,
bow in it.
How could it be praiseworthy?
The person threw himself on a hand grenade
knowing the result of this was that
he was going to die and so he killed a
person thereby apparently violating the
deontological right not to
have innocent people be killed.
Don't talk about the results
are better. Yeah, of course.
Five buddies saved results are better,
but that doesn't seem to enough to us
in our deontological moods after all.
Suppose that I see the hand grenade.
And so what I do is I take Jones
and throw him on the grenade. Oh,
that's not okay.
Even though the results are the same,
what makes the difference?
Why is it morally legitimate for
Jones to throw himself on the grenade?
The only answer that I can see his,
because he agrees to it.
He did it to himself, he
volunteered. It has his consent.
We throw away the consent principle.
We're forced to say what Jones
did isn't morally admirable.
It's morally appalling.
It's morally forbidden.
I can't believe that. So we need a
consent principle. But on the other hand,
we don't want to go with such a strong
Concentra and supple that we say, oh,
it's okay to kill crazy people
are killed children, you know,
just because they say, Oh
kill me. So we need something,
a more moderate form of
the consent principle.
We need to say consent can do its thing,
but only under certain conditions.
What exactly are the relevant
conditions? Well, this is of course,
one more topic open for debate.
We might insist that look,
uh, the, the, the permissions
got any given freely.
It's gotta be given knowing what
the upshots are going to be.
It's got to be given by somebody
who's saying, who's rational,
who's competent, who's, and that may
deal with the child case as well,
who's not yet competent to
make this sort of decision.
There's room for disagreement about what
exactly are the relevant conditions to
put in to a proper version
of the consent principle.
We might also want to throw
in some requirement that
the person had good reasons
for his giving you permission.
That my deal with the case where you
just come up to me after class and say,
kill me. I mean, you're not insane
or at least might not be insane. Uh,
your,
you know,
what's going to happen in
some sense you've got the
Mitch the age of competence,
but you don't have any
good reasons for it.
Maybe that's enough to undermine
the force of consent. Well,
suppose we've got some kind
of modified consent principle.
What should we say about suicide then?
Well,
it seems to me what we're led to is
once again a modest view about suicide.
The mere fact that the person killed
themselves won't show that it was morally
legitimate because of course, even though
they've given themselves permission,
they may not have had, for example,
good reason or they might be insane.
But for all that,
if we can have cases and I take it,
we can have cases where somebody's
rationally assesses their situation,
sees that they're better off dead thought,
thinks the case through,
doesn't rush into it,
makes an informed and voluntary
decision with good reason behind it.
In a situation like that,
it seems to me that consent
principle might well come into play,
in which case consent will Trump or
nullify the force of the deontological
prohibition against
harming innocent people.
So suicide will again be
acceptable in some cases though,
not in all. And that's the conclusion
that seems to me to be the right one.
Whether we accept the utilitarian
position or one of these deontological
positions.
Suicide isn't always legitimate,
but it's sometimes legitimate
still leaves the question,
what should we do when we see,
when we come across somebody trying to
kill themselves and there I think there's
good reason to ask yourself,
are you confident that the person has
satisfied the conditions on the consent
principle?
Okay.
Perhaps we should err on the side of
caution and assume that the person may be
acting under distress, not
thinking clearly, not informed,
not altogether competent,
not acting for good reasons,
but to accept that is not to
accept the stronger conclusion.
That we must never permit somebody to
kill themselves if we become convinced
that they have thought it through.
If they do have good reason,
that they are informed that
they are acting voluntarily.
In some such cases it may be legitimate
for them to kill himself and for us to
let them.
Alright,
almost out of time.
So let me shift gears for the very last
time and take a quick look at where
we've been
starting this semester.
I invited you to think hard about the
nature of death or the facts about life
and death.
Most of us try very hard to
not think hard about death.
It seems to be an unpleasant topic
and we put it out of our mind.
We don't think about it.
Even when there's a sense in which it's
staring us in the face every single
class of this semester,
every single day of this semester.
You've come into this building and have
walked past a cemetery right across the
street.
How many times did you notice it?
How many times did you stop to think
about the complete visual reminder that we
are on this earth for awhile
and then we're not anymore.
Most of us just don't think about it.
Well of course you are in
some sense the exceptions.
You spent a semester thinking about it
and I will be largely content if you've
taken the opportunity this semester
to take a hard look at the things you
believe,
whether or not you ended up agreeing with
me about the various claims that I've
put forward is less important than that.
You've taken the chance to take a hard
look at your beliefs and ask yourself not
just what you're sort of hoped or
wished or kind of believed was true,
but what you could actually defend.
Still.
Having said that,
it would be disingenuous of me to pretend
that I don't also hope that you've
come around if you didn't start
out believing what I believe.
You've come around to
believing what I believe as a,
as I pointed out in the first day,
most people accept a great deal of this
package of beliefs about the nature of
life and death,
that they believe we have a soul,
that there's something more to us than
our bodies and they believe that because
they think given the existence of a
soul will have the possibility of living
forever in mortality is a possibility
and we all hope for and crave the
possibility that we will live forever
because death is and must be horrible.
It's so horrible that we
try not to think about it.
It's so horrible that when we do
think about it were filled with dread,
terror and fear,
and it's just obvious that that's the
only sensible reaction to the facts about
life and death.
Life is so incredible that
under no circumstances could
it ever make sense to be
glad that it had come to an end
in mortality would be desirable.
Suicide could never be
a reasonable response.
Over the course of this semester,
I've argued that that package of
beliefs common as it may be is mistaken
virtually from start to finish.
There is no soul.
We are just machines.
We're not just any old machine.
We are amazing machines.
We are machines capable of
loving, capable, of dreaming,
capable of being creative, capable of
making plans and sharing them with others.
We are people,
but we're just machines anyway,
and when the machine breaks,
that's the end.
Death is not some big mystery,
which we can't get our heads around.
Death is in some sense,
no more mysterious than the fact that
your lamp can break or your computer can
break or any other machine can,
will eventually fail.
Okay.
I never meant to claim that it's not
regrettable that we die the way we do.
As I argued when talking
about in mortality,
better still would be if only we had
the prospect of living as long as life
still had something left to offer
us as long as life would be good.
Overall death is bad and
I think for most of us,
death comes too soon,
but having said that,
it doesn't follow that in
mortality would be a good thing.
On the contrary in mortality
would be a bad thing.
Yeah.
The reaction that makes sense in thinking
about the facts of death are not just
find it as some great mystery, too
dreadful to think about too overwhelming,
but rather fear far from being the
rationally appropriate response,
I think is an inappropriate response.
Although it can be sad
that we die too soon.
That perhaps should be balanced by the
fact of the recognition of just how
incredibly lucky we all are
to have been alive at all.
Yet.
At the same time,
recognizing that sense of luck and
being fortunate doesn't mean that we're
always lucky to be remaining alive.
For some of us,
the time will come in which
that's no longer true,
and when that happens,
life is not something to be held on,
to come what may under
any and all circumstances,
the time could come for some of
us in which it's time to let go.
What I then invited you to do over the
course of the semester is not only to
think for yourself about
the facts of life and death,
but I invite you all to come to face
death without fear and without illusion.
Thanks very much.